you're probably right I don't need to
really talk to anybody else because you
after all are the biggest pig in Show
Business oh thank you whoopy dear thank
you there's a lot of competition now
it's tough for a mature pig to get work
these days don't I know
it all right now now that I'm on the
show how would you like me to save it
with my unique brand of stop hour listen
Miss Piggy I think the satellite's about
to pass I've got it I've got it we'll
close with one of those Sensational
production numbers I call it pork Kus
you see ladies and Gentlemen please a a
big hand for the one and only thank God
Miss Piggy oh you like mu you really
like M oh thank you thank you whoy
whatever yes
good whoopy can you see me well that's I
I can't really are are you there oh oh
beautifully done thank you listen we're
starting to lose you again so we better
say good night